c'est une aventure qui nous attend une
aventure comme peu de voyageurs peuvent
la vivre
je m'appelle eric je suis à gauche dans
l'image et mon comparse c'est axel
depuis des années ensemble nous aimons
baroud et dans les endroits les plus
absurdes de la planète
et croyez-nous chaque pays comporte son
lot de bizarreries la chine est notre
première destination et ce n'est pas le
pays le plus facile
[Musique]
en chine on ne peut pas tourner sans
autorisation alors nous nous sommes fait
passer pour de simples touristes mais
nous n'allons pas vous faire découvrir
la grande muraille de chine ni même la
cité interdite mais des lieux bien plus
insolites comme cette ville fantôme où
les habitants semblent s'êtres
volatilisés
je m'imagine alors en plein film
apocalyptique
c'est un peu comme s'il y avait eu un
virus
nous vous emmenons à la découverte d'un
pays aux mille paradoxe quarante ans
après sa mort et malgré ses millions de
victimes à otc tung continue d'être
vénérée regardez la réaction des gens
vous allez voir ses sosies sont de vrais
rockstar chacun son tour chacun son tour
comble de l'ironie le dictateur
communiste est aujourd'hui synonyme de
business vive le peuple
mais dans cette chine où l'argent coule
à flots
le communisme n'a pas encore dit son
dernier mot
notre voyage commence au centre du pays
dans un monde que l'on pensait disparues
en chine depuis de nombreuses années
anand j nous allons découvrir les règles
pour le moins étonnante qui régissent la
vie des habitants
[Musique]
ces modes de locomotion humaniste
c'est si les rats ils commandent taxi et
là les rouges et betty carter est petit
nous nous dirigeons vers la dernière
ville chinoise à vivre selon les
préceptes purs et durs du communisme
[Musique]
vous y êtes ça fait 1 euro une enclave
dans une chine devenue ultra capitaliste
alors l'un c'est une frontière invisible
c'est ça dairy milk en fait l'entrée du
village communiste la ville normale qui
est là avec la vie commune
tout est propre tout est aligné les
trottoirs sont nickel et
dès qu'on va le côté il ya des magasins
partout et surtout il ya des publicités
partout ici en europe pas de publicité
ici
fatalisme
[Musique]
enfin de l'autre côté ce n'est pas
forcément mieux
les affiches de mao remplace les
panneaux publicitaires
[Musique]
pour ne pas éveiller les soupçons
nous nous faisons passer pour de bons
camarades communistes à l'effigié de mao
et bien sûr le best seller locale le
petit livre rouge
nous sommes prêts pour une visite en
bonne et due forme aux côtés de l'un des
nombreux guides qui font découvrir aux
touristes ce disneyland communiste
en amont
à droite vous pouvez observer notre
usine de fabrication de bière ici c'est
une maison médicale les villageois
il profite de soins médicaux gratuits
ici c'est une usine de nouilles
instantanées
la ville compte 26 usines qui
appartiennent toutes au parti communiste
local l'argent qu'elle dégage est
entièrement réinvestis dans la
communauté
un collectivisme qui semble fonctionner
à merveille pour les 4000 habitants de
nantes j'ai presque tout est gratuit
école soins médicaux eau électricité et
même les logements comme tient à nous le
montrer notre guide en nous ouvrant les
portes d'une famille modèle et c'est par
là
[Musique]
vous pouvez entrer bonjour ils n'ont pas
de loyer à payer mais il ya quand même
une contrepartie s'est livré avec
l'appartement décoration mouse et 2 qui
choisissent le portrait de mao et sept
affiches font partie du package on a
tout ça grâce à lui ça leur rappelle
qu'ils lui doivent tout les règles de
vie obligatoire pour garder
l'appartement sont clairement affichées
ne pas trahir le communisme obéir à tout
prix éviter le luxe ne pas se saouler et
sa beauté l'ordre public
si vous respecter ces règles
ici tout est gratuit la télévision les
casseroles le canapé c'est vraiment le
paradis communiste on highway c'est le
top ici
si vous n'êtes pas d'ici soit tu te
maries à quelqu'un du village
ou alors tu mariton enfants à quelqu'un
du village
alors on n'a qu'à se marier ensemble
je suis déjà marié dommage pour axel car
ici terminé les problèmes d'argent que
l'on soit ouvrier ou ingénieurs tout le
monde touche le même salaire
il est crédité sur une carte qui permet
d'acheter seulement dans les magasins
municipaux c'est comme une carte
bancaire avec ça je peux tout acheter
les courses du quotidien et même les
vêtements
le village ne donne l'équivalent de 130
euros par mois et par habitant
c'est le bonheur absolu ici le bonheur
absolu bas
beaucoup de gens veulent habiter au
village esneu et vous vous êtes du
village
non je viens d environ et vous aimeriez
venir habiter ici
bien sûr c'est un rêve de vivre ici
enfin mieux ne vaut pas faire le
difficile
dans les magasins municipaux le choix
est limité l'essentiel des produits sont
chinois si vous ne trouvez pas votre
bonheur
pas de panique en plus de la carte vous
avez droit à un peu de liquide 40 euros
pour vos achats à l'extérieur de la
ville
on se dit que tout est trop beau pour
être vrai il y as forcément un revers à
la médaille
[Musique]
le lendemain surprise
des chants révolutionnaires nous tire du
lit dès 6h du matin
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]
oh
tous les jours pendant deux heures des
haut parleurs disposés partout en ville
chante la gloire de mao axel n'a pas
vraiment l'air d'apprécier
les chants se termine par quelques
conseils de savoir-vivre niveau ce matin
là nous nous rendons siège du parti pour
savoir comment fonctionne exactement le
système communautaire du village et on
ne va pas être déçu
[Musique]
le responsable du parti communiste nous
explique que pour vivre à angie il faut
accepter les règles de la délation
ici tout le monde surveille tout le
monde
ce sont les voisins qui font
l'évaluation il contrôle par exemple
l'hygiène les moeurs ou aussi les
relations conjugales et il en voit les
résultats nos services
cette enquête a lieu tous les deux mois
elle détermine votre niveau de salaire
et d'autres avantages comme la prise en
charge du médecin ou encore votre
facture d'eau alors mieux vaut se tenir
à carreau la meilleure note
ces dix étoiles tout est pris en charge
à 9 étoiles c'est 90% et ainsi de suite
et si un membre de la famille perd une
étoile alors tous les membres de la
famille perdre une étoile le contrôle
sur les habitants est totale de leur
attitude dépend leur niveau de vie
maintenant nous ne voyons plus le
village du même oeil
tous les deux on trouve d'un seul coup
que les regards se portent un peu trop
sur nous
[Musique]
nos impressions se confirme sur la
promenade familiale
je vais vous dire qu'ils sont tous ces
gens d'aimer 6/2 et notre président en
face ce qui lui glisse et joseph staline
je ne sais pas ce qu'il a fait mais il
devait être très important il est juste
devant la photo de notre président qui
dit bizarre cette femme qui nous
interpelle spontanément après plusieurs
minutes
notre interprète arrive à la faire
parler je surveille les rues et je
m'assure qu'il n'y ait pas d'étrangers
elle a une mission qui lui est donnée
par les autres habitants de la ville
c'est de surveiller la ville pas qu'ils
aient des étrangers qui s'infiltrerait
dans le quartier donc elles patrouillent
avec sa collègue et doit dénoncer tout
de suite si un inconnu en village et
c'est exactement ce qu'elle va faire
alors que je continue de rencontrer les
habitants
sous le regard des héros du communisme
je fais l'objet d'un contrôle de police
que je ne peux filmer bien sûr vingt
minutes après je retrouve axel c'est un
village un peu prison quand même il
pense lui aussi que nous sommes sous
surveillance et là vous avez un monsieur
avec des lunettes de soleil qui nous
suit depuis tout à l'heure après fait
semblant de passer comme si de rien
n'était mais il nous prend faute ou de
loin on peut penser que c'est quand même
un espion les cons nous un truc photo
photo
[Musique]
nous quittons angie
avec axel on a du mal à comprendre les
chinois sont-ils communiste ou bien
capitaliste les deux systèmes semblent
s'affronter au sein de la population
parfois même les deux idées se mélangent
cela a donné naissance au capitalisme
rouge
un système unique en son genre dans
lequel le communisme est relégué au rang
de folklore c'est ce que nous allons
découvrir achats au chan la ville natale
de mao
un lieu de pèlerinage qui ferait se
retourner dans sa tombe le grand
timonier superbe montre il salue c'est
génial la montre de beaucoup à nos
voisins avec mao sur la même ligne
nous sommes les seuls étrangers à faire
du tourisme rouge
sitôt le grand leader s'affiche dès
l'entrée de l'autoroute
une fois passé la barrière de péage il
faut déjà mettre la main au portefeuille
[Musique]
chaque personne
que chaque pays a des dents
on rêve
dans ses formes le darfour
et c'est loin d'être fini
c'est une usine qui a eu l'autorisation
de la part de la famille demande de
reproduire un petit effort ce qui est
étrange c'est quand on l'a un peu boulot
là tout réaliste et l'est vraiment sous
toutes ses formes et je me mets à couper
à la fois les circuits mais il va rien
bouger une belle boutique pour acheter
d'état de stature erauw bonjour on peut
visiter l'atelier
non non c'est interdit allez s'il vous
plaît non j'adore mao
bon d'accord mais après vous sortez bien
sûr et vous fabriquez combien de statut
par mois on parle entonne entre 4 et 5
tonnes par mois
vous abordez partout en chine
elle est trop lourde fait le tour pour
bien la voir dans la boutique souvenir
mao tsé toung est décliné sous toutes
ses formes en sets de table sur des
briques et
et même en boule à neige le chef de la
révolution est devenu un énorme business
voilà maintenant mao élevé au rang de
dieu
un comble lui qui a tenté d'éradiquer
toutes les religions de chine
encore aujourd'hui il est interdit d'
appartenir à une religion si l'on veut
entrer au parti communiste chinois
le pompon de la visite se trouve dans
cette pièce qui maintenant mao nous
parle depuis l'au delà
en fait sa voix est là pour motiver les
visiteurs à sortir quelques billets de
plus
[Applaudissements]
et ça marche tout le monde semble croire
aux vertus magiques de la carte mao et
comme on était vraiment gentil malrucien
petite bise
ça porte chance oui si vous avez payé ça
marche
en 27 ans de pouvoir mao envoyés à la
mort près de 50 millions de chinois avec
axel on a bien du mal à comprendre
pourquoi il est encore autant adulé les
chinois ont-ils la mémoire courte ou le
parti at il réécrit l'histoire au fur et
à mesure des années la seconde hypothèse
semble la bonne cette période est
considéré comme des années très noir
pour la chine mao n'y est pour rien vous
pensez que mao n'est pas responsable
non les idées de mao était bonne mais il
a été manipulé par sa femme aussi elle a
bon dos la femme de mao quand même avec
axel nous décidons de tenter une petite
expérience
les chinois sont ils vraiment tous fans
de l'ancien dictateur
pour le savoir nous avons loué un sosie
et il est là en personne ses pieds quel
honneur dans sa môman nous l'avons
emmené se promener en ville
ouais avant j'étais j'étais chauffeur
regardez cette photo
voyez comme je lui ressemble c'est le
même moyen
on fait le même poids et la même taille
la première règle à respecter quand on
joue mal c'est de toujours mettre sa
main dans le dos c'était la posture du
dictateur chinois
la deuxième cultivé en permanence sa
ressemblance avec le tyran et ça
comporte beaucoup davantage
moi la police ne m'arrête jamais et si
jamais les policiers m'arrête
ils me reconnaissent et me laisse
repartir après quelques minutes de
discussion
nous constatons qu'à force de jouer les
mao notre sosie on a pris les travers
simao était vivant il n'y aurait pas
autant de millionnaires ils auraient
fait tuer tous les corrompus
tous ceux qui ont touché des enveloppes
une fois descendu de voiture up la main
dans le dos
regardez la réaction des gens vous allez
voir regardez regardez sur av
le peuple m'adore première et c'est dans
un musée qui lui est consacré prends-moi
en photo avec lui viens viens prendre la
photo je l' ai vu en premier alors là
forcément sa cote de popularité est de
100%
on se l'arrachent même notre faux mao je
veux prendre une photo seul avec lui
chacun son tour
vous attendez votre tour
vive le peuple ça vous fait quoi de voir
mao tu fais une interview maintenant on
est des touristes français adacore vous
faites le tourisme rouge
bonjour alors ça vous fait quoi de voir
le sosie de mao j'ai pris des superbes
photos
[Musique]
une fois dans la rue
l'engouement semble le même il y a ceux
qui prennent des photos ce qui au juste
un regard
[Musique]
et dans ce restaurant il n'aura pas le
temps de s'asseoir que tout le monde lui
saute dessus
[Musique]
même les occidentaux en vacances veulent
leurs clichés
notre maillot a le sourire il est fier
de nous montrer à quel point le grand
timonier populaire jusqu'au moment où
l'on pose la question qui fâche
je ne veux pas parler de ça on savait
qu'il ne faut pas en parler
[Musique]
tabou car s'il aimait la moindre
critique
il perd son statut de sosie officiel le
gouvernement chinois veut gommer tous
les dérapages de la révolution
culturelle de mao tsé toung difficile
car elle a surtout été une période de
terreur dans les années 70
et
en voilà un petit résumé tout le pays
devait apprendre par coeur les préceptes
du petit livre rouge
le credo
si tu ne comprends pas ce n'est pas
grave exécute quand même tu comprendra
plus tard
les plus récalcitrants étaient envoyés
dans de terribles camps de rééducation
ils ont été des millions à y perdre la
vie
[Musique]
mao a beau être mort depuis 40 ans cette
erreur a laissé des traces
surtout que sa pensée est encore très
présent dans la vie politique chinoise
le gouvernement s'en sert comme d'un
exemple à suivre
avec axel on se rend compte qu'en chine
il est encore difficile de s'exprimer
librement
exemple avec notre jeune guide
touristique pour avoir osé nous dire que
mao n'intéresse plus les jeunes
elle va avoir droit à un sérieux rappel
à l'ordre le tourisme rouge est un
succès mais il intéresse surtout les
anciens les jeunes
mao ce n'est pas trop leur truc jamais
très loin
sa supérieure la reprend aussitôt mais
non c'est pas vrai il ya plein de jeunes
dans les groupes
ici tout le monde le sait on aime touch
mouse est vraie elle a raison à partir
de cet instant elle ne pourra plus nous
parler ouvertement
elle sera cornaquer de près la pression
du régime est discrète mais réelle
le meilleur moyen de contrôler les
masses et d'encadrer sa jeunesse et pour
cela il faut bien sûr les ducs et dès le
plus jeune âge on va aller visiter un
camp d'entraînement pour les jeunes
chinois sur le thème des soldats rouges
bonjour c'est vous qui avait appelé pour
venir des activités avec les jets de
grenades ans plus tôt une porte des
charges aussi attraper les méchants
propriétaires terriens
on reste sur une thématique communiste
où le gentil et le paysan est le méchant
et le bourgeois ou le japonais
alors on y va on déguise en général
cochon le général cochon c'est la
caricature du bourgeois qui s'empiffrent
exploite les gentils villageois et
enlèvent leurs enfants pour le combattre
il mao a créé une unité d'élite
les gars de rouge
[Musique]
yb
quinze ans d'âge et environnement je ne
sais tu pas regarde devant toi c'est le
tout seul là je la mange ta maman j'ai
peur allez passade dents
[Musique]
dans les années 60 les gars de roujan
relais des enfants de cet âge
il s'entraînait sur le même genre de
parcours du combattant et certaines
techniques ont rendu l'armée de mao
victorieuse
les échasses qui était plus grande à
l'époque ont permis à l'armée de
traverser des marais bon c'est pas
simple soldat de l'armée rouge
s'improvise pas avec ces skis de bois
les soldats marché à l'unisson en ne
laissant que peu de traces les parents
sont fiers des exploits de leurs petits
mais il ya un détail qu'il semble avoir
gommé de leur mémoire
[Applaudissements]
ces familles ont oublié que les gardes
rouges étaient loin d'être détendre sous
mao
ce sont eux qui menaient la chasse aux
intellectuels et aux bourgeois soi
disant ennemi du régime
ils sont responsables de centaines de
milliers de morts
tous les deux on s'étonne de voir ces
familles aisées offrir à leurs enfants
ce stage façon gardes rouges tué un
soldat rouge de rangement ta tablette
regarde ton père je vais faire des
photos
les bourgeois qui entraînent leurs
enfants à faire la chasse aux bourgeois
c'est à n'y rien comprendre
soit un capitaliste c'est pas malin toi
tu en japonais et ça c'est un bourgeois
il faut tous les éliminés sous forme de
jeu
le message s'installe doucement dans
l'esprit des enfants attrapent et de
japonais bourgeois venez on les emmène
au tribunal
approchez-vous les soldats rouges
vous allez crier à bas les bourgeois
avec les points bien fermé à bas les
monstres japonais
les japonais nous ont envahis et on ne
les aime pas les japonais ont occupé la
chine pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
le japonais restent méchant et au jour
d'aujourd'hui on a toujours la haine du
vilain japonais nous sommes troublés
les chinois ont ouvert des attractions
où l'on peut s'entraîner à tuer des
japonais j'étais au 15 mai les japonais
ne sont pas les seules cibles
[Musique]
axel entre dans la peau d'un soldat
communiste et moi je serai dans l'armée
taïwanaise contre laquelle mao a livré
de nombreuses batailles
j'étais attrapé ne bouge pas venez voir
une reconstitution de la bataille contre
le taïwanais c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu comme si encore aujourd'hui en
france on faisait des institutions
accoutrement et qu'on les ridiculiser
surtout contre eux grâce à trois drops
c'est tout ce faire tout se fait dans
une ambiance très détendue
tu vas là-bas et toi tu vas là-bas
dépêche toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
10 euros la boîte a commencé ici les
nationalismes l'attaqué sournoisement
les gentils village
[Musique]
ok
forcément l'armée de mao et victorieuse
[Rires]
pendant tout notre périple nous aussi
nous sommes une curiosité pour les
chinois surtout les jeunes femmes très
demandeuse de photos et d'action là sur
ces terribles ici parce qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de voir trop d'étrangers
alors quand il voit de là haut
deux étrangers l'attraction
pourtant le gouvernement incite les
chinoises à se méfier
derrière chaque étranger se cacherait un
espion potentiel pour être encore plus
clair
pékin a même fait éditer une bd
l'histoire de la jeune lee une
fonctionnaire du comité central qui
rencontre un étranger et arrive ce qui
devait arriver vous êtes belle
gentil vous avez du talent je suis tombé
amoureux de vous puis l'homme se montre
de plus en plus curieux sur ses
activités au parti ma chérie ne garde
pas de secret pour moi
montre moi tout est rapport c'est juste
pour ma culture personnelle par amour
la jeune femme lui remet des documents
confidentiels
sauf que le don juan était un espion
la pauvre lee finit bien sûr en prison
cette bd surréaliste a été affichée
partout dans les grandes villes est
l'une des plus grandes se trouve dans le
nord du pays
mais cette ville a une particularité que
les autorités tentent de cacher selon
les chinois
ordos sorti de terre il ya seulement
quelques années serait l'une des plus
belles cités de l' empire du milieu
[Musique]
la ville d'ordos se trouvent à 700
kilomètres de la capitale pékin
[Musique]
à quelques minutes de notre arrivée
première surprise la ville a été
construite en plein milieu du désert
[Musique]
l'aéroport est de classe internationale
et pourtant on y compte que trois avions
avec le nôtre
[Musique]
bizarre les halls sont quasi vides
dimensionnée normalement il ya manami
qui nous attend ravi de vous rencontrer
madame lee c'est notre guide et elle est
bien étonnés de voir débarquer des
étrangers vraiment intriguant nous
sommes en pleine semaine et tous les
parkings sont vides mais que se
passe-t-il à ordos madame il nous fait
croire que tout va bien elle nous remet
un guide des plus beaux endroits à
visiter
lisez ce guide
[Musique]
c'est la plus belle ville de toute la
chine
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure que l'on s'approche
d'ordos nous nous rendons compte qu'il
ya quelque chose qui cloche
tout semble à l'image de l'aéroport vide
l'autoroute géante ne compte que
quelques voitures
[Musique]
et tout le monde semble jouer à faire
semblant la police surveille des
carrefours vide
[Musique]
les cantonniers balaye des routes que
les rares voitures n'arrive même pas à
salir
[Musique]
ces six heures c'est l'heure de pointe
c'est sa saisir leurs déboires
entre
c'est mal
c'est l'embouteillage locale
comment ils ont réussi à se rentrer
dedans
[Musique]
avec axel nous nous posons la même
question mais où sont donc passés les
habitants d'ordos la ville est pourtant
censé accueillir près d'un million de
personnes
pendant bon ville de cette taille là il
faut un choc neurones c'est à dire un
centre commercial de très grande taille
suez en sont très fiers alors bienvenue
sur le commercial
klaus
by a pas foule un nom mais surtout il ya
des comètes juste sur la chaussée on
pourrait penser qu'après regarde bien
oui c'est l'affluence des grands jours
non là c'est la vie d'une phantom c'est
un peu comme s'il y avait eu un virus
des tous morts
qui dit adhérer la dernière descente
le mascara fonctionne pas pourtant c'est
vrai quand même des produits avons alors
eu speak english non à l'eau donc il ya
des magasins
il n'ya pas les commerçants à herat
bonjour voila vous voulez des chemises
une ville fantôme un centre commercial
désert mais selon la guide
il n'y a pas matière à se poser de
questions les habitants se trouverait
soit au travail soit chez eux
d'ailleurs officiellement tous les
appartements de la ville ont été vendues
avec axel on trouve quand même ça
bizarre nous lâchons notre guide pour
nous engouffrer dans un taxi nous
racontons chauffeur que nous voulons
acheter un appartement
il nous conduit dans l'un des plus beaux
quartiers de la ville une surprise nous
y attend
on voit c'est là on est dans ce qui se
fait de mieux dans la ville est plutôt
calme a pas un chat mais à l'intérieur
nous sommes accueillis par une armée
d'agents immobiliers bonjour chercher
quels types d'appartements grand grand
de la hauteur sous plafond
veuillez attendre ici on est pris au
sérieux
suivez-moi de 140 appartements mais ses
290 appartement il ya des gens qui sont
là parce que l'on voit personne tu as
contre il ya des propriétaires mais ils
ne sont pas largués pas d'ampezzo ita
aucun habite à ordos en réalité sur les
290 appartement du complexe seuls 40
sont vendus et on va vite comprendre
pourquoi ces immeubles existe déjà
depuis 5 ans et beaucoup d'appartements
se trouvent encore dans cet état hockey
awards et celui là il fait combien de
mètres carrés 350 mètres carrés c'est un
duplex
on est bien là
voilà en quartier fantôme
les deux habitants annoncé déjà vu les
seuls habitants sont les jardiniers
combien ça vaut quand même quand même
[Musique]
443 1571 euros selon les agents ce prix
défient toute concurrence
et même si c'est à nous de finir les
travaux d'après elle on est assuré de
faire un bon achat nous sommes dans
l'hyper centre
votre investissement assure ici d'autant
plus que cette ville est réputée pour sa
beauté
les gens des autres villes disent tous
corps dos est l'endroit idéal
tous les visiteurs disent oh comme c'est
calme ici il n'ya pas de bruit à lasser
certains il n'ya pas de voisins petit
détail supplémentaire à ce prix là vous
êtes seulement locataire pour 70 ans
tous les biens immobiliers appartiennent
à l'état chinois
des swan et ce bâtiment ce sera quoi une
galerie marchande et il sera terminé
bientôt dans deux ans là je reste
perplexe
il y a peu de chances que les travaux
des immeubles d'ordos soit finir jours
mais alors que s'est-il passé dans cette
ville
pourquoi est-elle à l'arrêt
[Musique]
au départ ordos n'est qu'une simple
ville minière exploitant le charbon qui
se trouve en abondance dans le désert
avec le boom économique chinois son
charbon alimente une grande partie des
centrales électriques du pays
des milliards de yuans entre dans les
caisses
grâce à ce trésor de guerre en 2009 le
maire d'ordos commencent à bâtir une
cité qui se veut légal de pékin ou de
shanghai
mais en 2011
tout bascule l'état ferme les centrales
les plus polluantes à ordos l'argent
cesse de couler à flots les
constructions s'arrête net
la ville était prête pour plus d'un
million d'habitants mais plus personne
ne vient s'y installer des rêves de
grandeur
il ne reste plus que des centaines de
coquilles vides comme ce délire
mégalomaniaque
je suis impressionné par ses
infrastructures
gigantesque c'est les prochains jeux ou
qui vont avoir lieu là bas l'impression
qu'ils ont créé un centre sportif pour
une ville de 15 millions d'habitants
m
25 ans 2000 habitants ici le stade doré
a coûté aussi cher que le stade
olympique de pékin
l'autre souci c'est que tout est
tellement démesuré quand on marche
les distances sont extrêmement longues
donc il nous faut des heures pour aller
sur un point a à un point b
et puis surtout si ça suffisait pas un
stade hop il y en a un autre là c'est la
patinoire et encore 1 et le stade de
basket par ici pour entrer dans ses
stades
pas besoin de prendre rendez vous les
hôtesses sont tellement contente d'avoir
des visiteurs qu'elle ne demande même
pas pourquoi on est là
impressionnant elle a un ballon à ici
lien n'a pas ces stades est énorme
il fait 134 mille mètres carrés et il
peut accueillir jusqu'à 60 mille
spectateurs soit dix mille de plus que
tous les habitants d'ordos réuni ce
stade de foot est le quatrième plus
grand de chine mais il y encore plus
dingue
la ville ne possède aucune équipe de
football on écoutait de la mer je suis
vraiment désolé pour le ballon et en
plus personne ne répond
quarante ans après la mort de mao la
chine semble encore se chercher entre
l'ultra capitalisme et communisme
[Musique]
en apparence tout semble aujourd'hui
identique à notre mode de vie
mais dès que l'on gratte un peu le vrai
visage du régime apparaît
interdiction de critiquer censure des
médias et d'internet
paranoïa envers les étrangers
pour les 1 milliard 350 millions de
chinois mieux vaut se fondre dans la
masse que s'opposer au régime
[Musique]